[Música]
se suspende el paro Cívico que había en
la ciudad boliviana de Santa Cruz de la
Sierra desde hace 36 días los líderes
accedieron a desbloquear las carreteras
de la región más rica debido a que el
congreso Avanza en el debate sobre el
censo poblacional
el gobierno de Venezuela y la oposición
logran un acuerdo para que dinero
Estatal que está congelado se destine a
gastos humanitarios con la gestión de la
ONU Estados Unidos respondió permitiendo
que la petrolera Chevron vuelva a operar
en suelo venezolano analizamos en
minutos
y Argentina sigue vivo en el mundial de
Qatar mientras que Francia se convirtió
en el primer equipo en confirmar su paso
a octavos de final las dos elecciones
ganaron frente a México y Dinamarca
respectivamente ampliamos desde doha con
nuestros enviados especiales
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de Francia 24 los saluda a
María Clara calle
iniciamos en Bolivia porque los líderes
cívicos levantaron temporalmente del
paro que comenzaron hace 36 días en
Santa Cruz de la Sierra decidieron
desbloquear las carreteras ya que el
congreso reactivó la discusión de un
censo que el presidente Luis Arce había
postergado hasta 2024 la cámara baja Ya
aprobó el proyecto y ahora lo debatirá
del senado si se aprueba la ley que
permitiría a la región más rica de
Bolivia tener más escaños en el
legislativo
tras 36 días levantan la huelga en Santa
Cruz de la sierra la cámara de diputados
bolivianas decidió que el censo que
había frenado el presidente Luis Arce se
celebrará el 23 de marzo de 2024
[Música]
que esperamos también contribuya a la
falsificación a la unidad de nuestro
país y ojalá que hoy
empiece también a levantarse la medida
de presión que nunca fueron necesarias
la ley fue aprobada por dos tercios de
la cámara baja y fue enviada al senado
para su revisión antes de que sea
promulgada por el presidente Arce el
censo el primero en más de una década
permitirá que los escaños del Congreso
sean redistribuidos antes de las
elecciones generales de 2025
la oposición había acusado al gobierno
de querer retrasarlo ya que el
oficialismo podría salir afectado en las
elecciones generales los líderes de
Santa Cruz anunciaron que aún siguen
pendientes de la completa aprobación de
La Ley a partir de este momento
hacemos un cuarto intermedio
levantamos el paro y bloqueos sin
suspender nuestra lucha
seguimos en emergencia en la región más
grande de Bolivia rica en soya la huelga
dejó mil millones de dólares en pérdidas
según el Ministerio de finanzas Mire ya
yo andaban nervioso ansioso medio Bravo
medio triste Pero por fin hoy una buena
noticia que volvemos a la normalidad los
resultados del censo se entregarán en
septiembre por lo que podrán aspirar
nuevos representantes políticos y
obtener asignaciones económicas para la
región
los diálogos entre el gobierno
venezolano de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición se reanudaron con un nuevo
acuerdo las partes intentarán recuperar
dinero Estatal que está bloqueado en el
sistema financiero internacional por las
sanciones que enfrenta Venezuela el
objetivo es invertirlo en gastos
humanitarios era una decisión que se
esperaba y a la cual Estados Unidos
permitió o respondió mejor que la
petrolera Chevron reanudar a sus
operaciones en territorio venezolano
para hablar del tema nos acompaña desde
Caracas Oswaldo Ramírez experto en
campañas electorales y director de orc
consultores señor Osvaldo Gracias por
estar con nosotros cuéntenos qué se sabe
desde la operación del dinero es decir
cuánto es cuando lo tendrían disponible
y Cómo se elige En qué invertirlo
Buenas noches María claro un placer
saludarles lo primero es entender que es
un fondo que pudiera estar pivotando
entre 2.800 millones de dólares y según
conocimos hoy pudiera llegar a ser hasta
cinco mil millones de dólares que
claramente pudieran estar en periodos de
hasta tres años entrando administrados a
través de la ONU de diferentes agencias
de la ONU específicamente para atender
inicialmente temas ligados a la
estabilización de los hospitales o el
tema ligado a la salud al tema ligado a
la educación claramente hay una
prioridad importante parte importante
del programa de alimentos sobre todo
para atender a poblaciones mayores de
edad porque inicialmente estuvo
concentrada esta ayuda humanitaria que
menores de edad y entrar también de
manera significativa en la
estabilización de servicios públicos
principalmente en el tema eléctrico pero
también entendiendo que hay que atender
zonas vulnerables que recientemente por
el tema de las lluvias resultaron
bastantes
para lograr ese tema de generar una
relocalización de personas o tratar de
generar sistemas eléctricas Bueno pero
el tema central de las negociaciones son
las elecciones generales de 2024 porque
la oposición quiere garantías para
participar Mientras que el presidente
maduro aspira a tener un respiro
económico Que suba su popularidad en
este sentido como el acuerdo de hoy
impactaría en las votaciones
Mira para Nicolás Maduro claramente
pudiera ser favorecido por estos tramos
si bien Tú tienes un tramo que pudiera
estar derivado de toda esta ayuda de
estos fondos bloqueados la realidad es
que debido a la licencia que le amplía
Chevron la capacidad de operación la
capacidad de venta directa o de llevar
petróleo Estados Unidos pudiera por
temas indirectos favorecer a Nicolás
Maduro ahora la popularidad de Maduro
que hoy es 20% de acuerdo a los datos de
rc consultores del frikis que es la
encuestadora que está midiendo este tema
pudiera llevar a Nicolás Maduro a Elevar
al menos en 10-15 puntos porcentuales
esa evaluación de gestión el tema es que
no va a ser inmediato pudiéramos estar
viendo los primeros resultados por lo
menos en abril o junio del año que viene
debido que muchos de estos fondos pasan
por procesos licitatorios por procesos
de descongelamiento de fondos
directamente desde los del departamento
del tesoro norteamericano así como los
entendimientos que pueda haber entre las
partes o posición y gobierno
con las agencias de Naciones Unidas
Osvaldo Ramírez Gracias por estar con
nosotros
feliz noche para ustedes Gracias Lo
mismo para ustedes y cambiamos de
noticia porque
aparente brasileño Yair bolsonaron que
no había salido en público desde el 30
de octubre cuando se pronunció tras
perder la segunda vuelta de electoral
frente a Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
bolsonaro asistió al primer acto público
al que ha ido desde entonces y acudió a
una ceremonia de graduación de Cadetes
del ejército en Reséndez ubicado en el
estado de Río de Janeiro hoy sonaron
honró a los militares recién graduados
de la academia militar de águilas negras
donde el mandatario se graduó en 1977 Y
aunque fue no rompió su silencio
en noticias del mundial de Qatar hoy se
disputaron los cuatro partidos de los
grupos c y d Francia ganó y se convirtió
en el primer equipo en pasar a los
octavos y Argentina sigue viva en la
fase de grupos luego de su Victoria ante
México mientras que Polonia y Australia
fueron los otros vencedores de hoy desde
doha nuestra enviada especial Natalia
Ruiz giraldo nos hace un repaso de la
jornada
Argentina juega el fénix Polonia pinchó
La burbuja de Arabia Saudita y Francia
logró su revancha Esos son los tres
resultados importantes de esta jornada
con Argentina que se midió aquí en el
estadio de los usail ante el actriz
ganando dos goles por Cero en un partido
bastante difícil con muchísimas
interrupciones hasta 16 faltas en tan
solo la primera parte pero Argentina que
sale a flote gracias a dos generalidades
una de Leonel Messi y luego la segunda
de Enzo Fernández en todo caso lo que
ocurre con Argentina que por ahora
segundo de grupo se va a decir en el
último partido en donde la albi Celeste
se enfrentará a Polonia Polonia que a su
vez ganó hoy a Arabia Saudita dos goles
por cero los saudíes que se tuvieron que
enfrentar ante el bromuro de El Arquero
polacochesmi y dos goles uno de celenski
y el segundo de lewandowski el 9 que por
fin logra marcar en la mundial por el
lado de por fin ganaron a Dinamarca dos
goles por uno doblete de mbappé e los
dos hombres que hicieron los pases para
estos goles el primero esteo Hernández y
el segundo es un griezmann y con este
resultado de dos goles por uno pues ya
Francia tiene seis puntos y es la
primera selección aquí en Qatar 2022 en
estar en octavos de final
Vamos hasta Ucrania porque este sábado
se restableció la electricidad en gerson
según la presidencia la luz la
calefacción y el agua estaban cortadas
en la ciudad desde el 11 de noviembre
cuando los ucranianos retomaron el
control en la urbe ocupada por los rusos
sin embargo en el resto del país seis
millones de hogares incluidos 600.000 en
la capital kiev continúan sin
electricidad y los ataques de Rusia de
los sistemas energéticos siguen
una carrera contra el reloj mientras la
mitad de los habitantes todavía no
tienen electricidad el alcalde de la
ciudad acaba de expresar su gratitud a
los técnicos que restablecieron la
calefacción
quiero agradecerles a ustedes los 300
empleados de la compañía energética
templo de kiev ustedes quienes trabajan
día y noche gracias a ustedes podemos
anunciar hoy que el 97% de los hogares
tienen de nuevo calefacción las
temperaturas van bajando tener calor se
vuelve vital porque en Ucrania el
invierno está llegando y las
temperaturas han pasado bajo cero pero
Rusia sigue bombardeando las
infraestructuras civiles esenciales
dejando millones de ucranianos sin gas O
electricidad desde kiefa al norte hasta
udesal Sur desde las orillas del Bíper
al este hasta el VIP cerca de Polonia no
hago un llamamiento a todos por favor
hagan reservas de agua carguen sus
celulares piensen en las comunicaciones
Prepárense con sus familias en caso de
que caigan las conexiones
Esta es una foto del cielo ucraniano
tomada a principios de febrero por la
NASA y otra tomada este jueves
secundaciones unidas la falta de energía
en Ucrania este invierno podría llevar a
nuevos desplazamientos de la población
dentro de los cuales podría haber un
Éxodo afuera del país
que ha reprimido las protestas que
llevan más de dos meses el líder supremo
dijo que ellos habían sacrificado sus
vidas a pesar de que los activistas han
denunciado la muerte de 448 personas
durante las manifestaciones mientras que
un equipo de médicos reportó que 140
iraníes perdieron sus ojos por el uso
del armamento de las fuerzas de
seguridad la historia la trae Gabriel
la represión si viene Irán mientras las
manifestaciones entran en su tercer mes
en la provincia sudoriental de si están
balucci están las fuerzas de seguridad
abrieron Fuego contra los manifestantes
el viernes según los activistas decenas
de personas murieron o fueron heridas
tras la jornada de protestas las
manifestaciones fueron convocadas en
todo el país esta semana en Solidaridad
con el kurdistán que junto con el System
baluchistán ha sufrido particularmente
de la mortífera respuesta de las fuerzas
de seguridad el sábado el líder supremo
de Irán alejarme saludó el trabajo de
los basics una milicia islámica que ha
tomado parte en la represión del
movimiento vieron en estos asuntos
recientes que el pueblo perseguido de
basic se sacrificó para evitar que la
nación sucumbiera a la fuerza de un
grupo de asesinos Rebeldes analfabetos
esclavos se sacrificaron para evitar la
crueldad de otros según la agencia de
noticias de activistas derechos humanos
448 personas fallecieron desde el inicio
de las protestas que fueron convocadas
tras la muerte de masa a mini las
autoridades iraníes por su parte afirman
que unos 50 efectivos de las fuerzas de
seguridad murieron en las movilizaciones
este jueves el consejo de derechos
humanos de la ONU voto por la creación
de una investigación independiente sobre
la represión de las protestas pero eran
condenó la medida y dijo que era inútil
y representaba una violación de la
soberanía nacional del país
[Aplausos]
hay un nuevo récord de contagios de Kobe
19 en China al confirmarse
3648 casos hoy en comparación con los
cerca de 3.400 Del día anterior es decir
que es el cuarto día en el que se
superan los registros anteriores Y a
medida que crece el brote aumenta
también el descontento público contra la
restricciones de la política cero covid
sobre todo en lugares como Beijing y sin
yang
la paciencia se acaba en los vecindarios
de Beijing ante las severas
restricciones del gobierno chino
ciudadanos se enfrentan con los comités
de salud y también con la policía
restringieron nuestro edificio hace tres
días y en medio de la noche usaron esta
barra de madera para cerrar la entrada
escribiendo en ella fuera de servicio y
según los informes había personas en la
puerta impidiendo que los residentes
salieran esta mañana Cuando bajé vi esta
barra de madera y la quité porque creo
que es una cuestión de seguridad y ellos
no tienen derecho a sellar la puerta
protestas que no se limitan solo a
Beijing también en urunki y la capital
de yin yang donde el jueves 10 personas
murieron en un incendio presuntamente
por no haber podido escapar por los
cierres que viven y las complicaciones
que tuvieron los servicios de emergencia
para llevar a cabo los operativos de
rescate algo que las autoridades locales
no reconocen esto desencadenado la ira
en la región de mayoría huigur es decir
musulmana y contra la que las
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
denuncian que se cometen graves abusos
por el gobierno chino
mientras que en yum yo donde está la
mayor fábrica de iPhone del mundo
también protestan contra las condiciones
laborales y salariales en medio del
estricto encierro el gobierno defiende
la política de cero covid para evitar
colapsar el sistema de salud cuando un
tercio de las ciudades del país se
encuentra bajo confinamiento y en medio
de todo la economía se resiente
en minutos con más información
[Música]